the song feels so cinematic
and it does move very fast
i
wanted to kick some ass really badly
sabrina carpenter channels her inner
action star in the video for her new
single fast times and the 22 year old is
taking no prisoners he went brunette and
you were kicking some butt you know what
that is
that's range girl that's range
also in heels the the cake like heels
was was tricky and i
i give myself credit for that because
that was hard
there obviously are only so many things
in the world you can do but i really
think the more cinematic you go the more
fun you can kind of have did you channel
any of your favorite movies in this
totally i think like fashion inspiration
i took a lot from you know fast and
furious and charlie's angels and uh
i love tarantino films i love how you
know there's like a kitschy
sophistication to everything we took a
lot of inspiration but um but also made
it something i think different for the
song and for what it is now the single
is off sabrina's forthcoming album she's
been hiding clues about the name of the
project in past songs have your fans
figured it out yet
one of yeah someone did you saw it okay
you're the first person i've told that
because they keep asking me and i've
been like
well because also what's so interesting
too is i was scared of doing that i was
scared that they would come up with a
better title and i'd want to change it
they're like oh wait i didn't think of
that that's really good when can we
expect the full record
so it's coming out on no i'm kidding um
i was ready i was sorry
my friend also just i gave him a jump
scare um
no it's obviously this year um and i am
i'm so excited i'm nervous i'm scared
i'm all the things i think as you
normally would be to to put out
something that's like different or
something that just feels a little too
personal um so i think i think i've
spent a lot of time and obviously i
spent a pandemic kind of figuring it out
figuring out
the heart of what it really is and uh
yeah i couldn't be more excited so this
really feels like it's indicative of
my age and just like the choices that
you make and you know the things that
are thrown at you and just the way life
feels speaking of that you know
obviously last year there was a big news
story that would not go away about a
song that may or may not be about you
and you're probably with that blonde
girl
who always made me doubt
how badly did you want to shout i would
like to be excluded from this narrative
um
i
don't
know i don't know if i ever shouted
those words
um
i think if anything i was just there's a
lot of smiling and nodding
right you know right
there was a lot of keeping it cute and a
lot of um
and a lot of uh saying please and thank
you and being purchased and just
understanding that life is a journey and
it's a roller coaster and you never know
what's gonna be thrown at you and so
that was like a a really good example of
that fast times fast nights
[Music]
[Music]